good good morning all welcome to the J
Irwin Miller symposium is drawing dead
before we start this morning I just
wanted I just wanted to note a couple of
things as many of you know and the
second floor gallery the exhibit is
Massimo Scolari the representation of
architecture it's extraordinary show and
if you miss Massimo's talk on Thursday
night I know you'll be glad to see the
show in addition to that there is a an
exhibition of student work in the null
drawing studio which is immediately to
the right as you would leave this
auditorium and then additional student
work displayed around the third floor of
this building so I welcome you all to
take a look at that that those spaces
will all be open through the entirety of
this symposium today so so please do
take advantage of that today's panels
will occur as follows the first panel
entitled burning bridges questioning
practice will start immediately followed
by a lunch break and then at two o'clock
the second panel will resume in title
the critical act it will be followed by
a concluding address by Mario carpeau
and then a reception in the gallery so
without further ado I wanted to
introduce Turner Brooks who's a faculty
member in the school who will introduce
the panel
welcome welcome back and welcome our
this morning's speakers as a lover of
pyrotechnical and incendiary events I
cannot help feeling sympathetic to the
title of this morning session burning
bridges as I also appreciate the
tragical image of the broken pencil on
the poster but I'm actually hopeful that
our five speakers this morning are more
accurately described as bridge builders
although it's a corny or even literally
as makers of new pencils to connect
drawing by hand back to what it might
what might be its future for me the
driving element of a drawing is the mark
on the paper it's often complete
ambiguity as a single entity until it is
put together with other marks suddenly
then exploding into something that makes
palpable space and as weight and
atmosphere I'd love to meander and the
luminous spatial at Pune I love to
meander in the luminous spatial / number
of a surah or float through the moist
aqueous atmosphere of a William Turner
or be drawn into the depths of the Cross
hatchings of a pier in AZ prison they
are let off by some distant spiraling
stare to view a far-off infinity or to
discern in Leonardo's wild spiraling pen
marks deluge steamy metamorphic
metamorphosing landscapes or to follow
the subtly changing dancing outline of
an Ellsworth Kelly leaf that all of a
sudden pops magically into a
three-dimensional topography revealing a
deep valley starting with the mark such
drawings hold the body in space allow it
to slip from moments of intimacy to
those of immensity the ambiguity between
the mark and what it represents is the
miracle this is what I have not yet seen
in computer renderings my kind of
obsession where the mark actually
started and the only drawing court saber
took probably in 1963 at Yale from a
disciple of Josef Albers we actually
started drawing the word Yale then the
word Yale upside down
then the word Yale upside down and
backwards which is a trend a struggle
between the hand the eye and the mind it
went on to draw wheel and I draw
flowerpots finding marks to represent
the New York Times printing and then the
grand climax was actually a log of wood
where the idea was to find the mark for
the bark Yale was an all-male
institution at this point some of the
undergraduates got up to look into the
graduates to do longingly gazing at the
voluptuous nude that was posing there
the disciple of Albert said what's going
on in there is sheer indulgence and we
had to go back there are part the
drawing on the right is actually I just
lower right I just put up only done
about three days ago by a student in a
class as I'm giving on drawing and I
just liked it because I think it is very
much about finding the mark and I also
love it sort of ambiguity of bark maybe
its water maybe it's swirling clouds
maybe it's something else and look at a
representation the other point I want to
make is my representation is something
that has within it the power to prompt
the all-important imagination to leap
between itself and that which it
represents the magical power to launch
the imagination into visualizing rich
subtle possibilities the digital search
for a rendered representation of the
hyper real seems wrong and as the close
proximity to this reality our only and
inevitably I think disturbingly surreal
reading a representation depends on an
audience with Sensibility but to
extinguish that sensibility would be to
promote a world where we all become
pawns walking around at a creepy virtual
reality and I think it's unquestionably
true that the worst buildings are those
that look like they're renderings
finally for me the hand drawn sketch or
the crude model holds has the virtue of
holding an entire idea or set of ideas
in the state of fluid suspension from
which multiple possibilities can be
imagined and from which a core
sustaining idea emerges and evolves to
order secondary and tertiary layers of
meaning sometimes the clue as to the
direction of evolution is discovered
with a chance glance from an unsuspected
angle perhaps even a bottle that has
crashed upside down to the floor I don't
know swab would agree with that analysis
I have not seen these virtues so much in
digital drawings now on to the the
speakers with Julie Dorsey and Casey
Reese the hand is being brought back
into the computers drawing process it
would seem to me Julie is developing
instruments where the gesture of drawing
by hand thinking with the pencil
interfaces directly with the screen
Casey Reese's said I want programming to
be as immediate and fluid as drawing
Andrew wit relates the computer as a
drawing machine back to a more primitive
or primitive antecedents in the early
19th century indicating that parameter
designed is not after all such a recent
sudden apocalyptic event the
psychologist Marvin Cheung is involved
with the workings of the minds cognition
related the perception of time and space
I see his work is furthering the
explorations of our own Kent bloomer and
body memory and architecture ultimately
explaining how we can haptic ly navigate
within the spaces of the drawings and
paintings and buildings that we make
finally Patrick shoemakers shoemakers
engagement with the parametric design as
a response to infinite changing
variables of desire emanating from sight
a culture and program also fit this
image of the body's response to space
and the increasing possibilities of the
compatibility between the two our first
speaker is Julie Dorsey professor of
computer science here at ya
before Yale she was at MIT tennard into
the departments of both electrical
engineering and computer sciences GL's a
degree in architecture as well she's
been developing methods of breaking down
the gulf between typing into the
computer and thinking with a pencil in
hand her talk is titled exploring the
middle ground between sketch and object
Julie Thank You Turner for the
introduction it's a pleasure to be here
I found yesterday's discussions and
presentations to be enthralling and I'm
very much looking forward to continuing
the conversation today digital drawing
tools have evolved and now augment
traditional drawing methods letting us
move ideas into the computer and develop
them with two three-dimensional models
but drawing remains a cognitive process
that extends seeing and imagining I
contend that sketching is a medium of
discovery like no other and will
describe a computer graphics system
mental canvas which I've developed
together with my students and
collaborators that attempts to bridge
between traditional sketching and
three-dimensional modeling we use as a
starting point the traditional
sketchbook drawings that architects use
to experiment with various view sections
and details rather than interpret or
infer 3d structure from drawings our
system is designed to allow the designer
to organize concept drawings in 3d and
gradually fuse a series of possibly
geometrically inconsistent sketches into
a set of 3d strokes our system uses
strokes and planar canvases as basic
primitives and the basic input of mode
of input is traditional drawing either
on paper or on the tablet
3d computer modeling systems have become
very successful in design and especially
in architecture in particular CAD
systems have become essential for the
development of complete documentation of
structures to be built CAD models are
often developed late in the design
process as a tool for documentation and
communication such a not such models an
able enable the precise specification of
materials in their configuration and can
be used both to perform both visual and
performance simulations recently there's
been considerable interest in 3d
modeling systems for the earlier phases
in design and sketching programs such as
Google Sketchup that allow users to
quickly define rough 3d definitions
using specific specified gestures and
commands have been developed many of
these programs follow a simplified form
of the procedure for the finding of
structure in a more sophisticated CAD
system larger masses are defined by
extruding building footprints details
subsequently added by defining small
geometric structures on these masses or
and by attaching texture maps to faces
of the building models at each point in
the process the user has a well-defined
3d shape to work with which can be
viewed from arbitrary points this
approach allows a user to experiment
with shape but facilitates just one of
many ways a user may want to develop a
design a classics example of a design
that could not be roughed out naturally
in a Cadillac system and in inspiration
for this project very close to home is
yells ingalls rink which I walk by every
morning in looking at cernan's early
sketches for the building once these
concepts ideas not yet fully formed and
loosely defined shapes the goal of
mental canvas is to provide the freedom
to experiment with similar
non-traditional and complex form
this to my mind requires a different
approach focusing on how a user can
organize concepts in 3d rather than on
many current efforts in modeling and
sketching research that attempt to
interpret simple sketches as 3d shape
architects of course have long used
sketching as an aid to visual thinking
in analysis and design this diagram
shows how seeing imagining and drawing
interact for example seeing facilitates
drawing while drawing invigorates seeing
drawing stimulates and expresses
imaginate imagining while imagining
provides impetus and material for
drawing and imagination directs and
filters seeing while seeing in turn
provides raw material for imagining
visual thinking's experienced to the
fullest when seeing imagining and
drawing merge into active interplay now
few people possess the ability to design
without drawings or other visual media
historically visual thinkers have
clarified and developed their thinking
with sketches for example Watson
recollecting the thinking that preceded
his discovery of the double helix
structure wrote that one important idea
quote came while I was drawing the few
strings of Enda 9 on paper and quote
often drawing and thinking are almost
simultaneous with the graphic image
appearing as an organic extension of
mental processes Edward Hill in his
language of drawing likens drawing to a
mirror a drawing acts as he said as the
reflection of the visual mind on its
surface we can probe test and develop
the workings of our particular vision
drawing not only helps to bring vague
inner images into focus it also provides
a record of the developing idea and
drawing provides a function that memory
cannot the most brilliant designer
cannot compare a number of images
side-by-side in memory
as he or she can compare a wall of
tacked up sketches I'm particularly
interested in drawings ability to extend
once thinking in contrast to drawing as
a means of communicating a well-formed
idea which of course is what cat is so
good at here are a couple of examples
sketches I'm very interested in the
notion of levels of abstraction that one
often sees in a single drawing or a
series of drawings that are assembled
together as you can see here by Louie
Cohn here we see verbal notation
orthographic projection and perspective
to probe is thinking from very
viewpoints and levels of abstraction and
here we see the dissecting capabilities
of drawing which a kami brother so well
eloquently described yesterday where
Leonardo is thinking about external
surfaces and internal structure at the
same time there can be no doubt that
computer modeling and fabrication allow
the representation and construction of
novel forms yet they may well impede
ideation in the early stages of design
as they require well-defined geometry no
matter the stage of the design process
drawing by not requiring geometry
supports speculation and in doing so
offers an incomparable aid to visual
thinking and discovery Henry Moore's
idea sketch is shown here instructive in
this regard they are concerned with the
gestalt of a sculptural idea with bold
patterns of light and shadow and with
overall relationships of line volume and
space abstraction allowed him to explore
many ideas quickly more noted that he
sometimes began sketching with nothing
in mind then discovered in an idea in
his doodlings as he put it drawing is a
means of finding your way about things
in a way of experiencing more quickly
than sculpture allows certain types of
tryouts and attempts so if drawing is so
valuable but is limited or even
discouraged by CAD systems where does
that leave us
our system aims to bridge sketching
bring sketching back into the picture a
pun intended in the remainder of this
talk I'm going to describe the mental
canvas or system and then demonstrate it
through a series of applications in
design and analysis this slide I think
was helpful especially in looking at
listening to talks yesterday and trying
to be very precise about what one can do
in different kinds of media this
describes 2d sketching versus 3d
modeling sketching of course is fast
fluid and expressive yet it's limited to
static views 3d modeling on the other
hand requires a precise geometric
description at all times yet it affords
the ability to change views our system
explores the space between these two
representations simply put you might
think of what we're doing is a beginning
where traditional sketching leaves off
CAD systems are designed to create
well-defined 3d models and then
automatically render views of them
rather than letting you use or draw a
view from scratch our work focuses on
allowing the user to draw 3d shapes as
an assembly of gestural strokes and to
easily move edit and refine those
strokes the core idea driving the
development of our system is to allow
users to develop coherency in 3d
gradually here we see two examples of
stroke make based models developed in
our system the user begins by creating
sketches in 2d and then is allowed to
pull apart and position the strokes in
the 2d sketches to begin to suggest a 3d
form the top sequence shows for sketches
sketched views of a house that are
positioned relative to one another in
the center and then a new view is
generated on the right the bottom shows
the development of a mixed-use complex
which was done by a actually an ax marks
here in the school a 3d sketch in our
system is built out of invisible planar
surfaces which we call canvases canvases
are positioned and rotated in 3d space
using the traditional CAD tools of
position rotate and scale on the three
coordinate axes using a tablet pen the
user can draw freely and also import
sketches from paper here he or she so
desires and can set down strokes on the
active canvas strokes can be pushed from
a particular view onto another canvas
allowing drawings to be moved in space
let me just the best way to describe
this is to just show you so here's a
simple editing session where we have a
canvas one canvas in the foreground and
designer we've sped this up obviously
for the purpose of demonstration of the
user can just sketch with strokes you
can do things like you can do with
regular paper and erase
we can also take a canvas and move it
around so this is like your drawing on
an overhead transparency and moving it
around in space we also have some other
tools that you don't have with paper you
can make certain pieces of the drawing
opaque so you can sort of turn a set of
strokes into a kind of surface here
we're now looking at up several
different canvases and this shows the
ability to add a new canvas and then you
can take some strokes from this active
canvas in the foreground and then
project them out onto another canvas in
the space this allows you for example to
start drawing in a perspective view and
then push things into a orthographic
projection if you will but the idea here
is that the canvases are just like
scaffolds they're holding strokes in
space and the form you see as a result
of the overlapping of these panels or
canvases this shows the ability all in
this concept of one drawing if you will
to show some details and also to add
annotations and up along the top you can
see what we call bookmarks which specify
some key views and their special cameras
that you can use as windows into the
world
here's just to drive this point home
about the Assembly of sketches and that
the form emerged from the overlap of the
sketches is this is a series of drawings
for a kind of opera house variety of
sketches at different scales and then
this is putting some of those drawings
together inside mental canvas so now
we're sort of looking at overlapping
views and we can we can manipulate the
transparency so what we're really seeing
here is in a 3d model at all it's just
strokes in space and what this allows is
for us to actually look at the
in-between space what happens between
views
this shows an example of some analytical
drawings developed by an unmarked
student here it's a son Connolly no a la
contro Fontaine Barbara meanie many of
you know so here are some photographs of
the courtyard and here are a set of
sketches that were drawn with our system
so they're just strokes again with some
annotation and now we can actually take
some of these drawings in and move them
around so instead of just having them as
pages in a sketchbook you can put them
together and here's a other sort of live
session recorded whoops where you can
see how some of these drawings can be
assembled together and this is going
inside the drawing again the only
representation here is two strokes on
canvas and now moving to the interior
the interior is obviously very
complicated and interesting as you move
from the bottom to the top the way that
the forms are arranged and so this is a
whole collection of analytical drawings
that were done of the interior with lots
of different views and different
components and different ways of
breaking the drawings apart and here
again is a a live view of the drawing or
model if you will inside mental canvas
it's as kind of as almost like you could
go inside your sketchbook and move
around and it shows a kind of dissect
ability of even within a drawing that
you can start to pull things apart and
this is an interesting one this is a
perspective drawing on a single canvas
and then so first you'll see the canvas
it's just a single plane and then after
it's been pushed out into a series of
additional canvases and you can see that
the perspective doesn't quite work and
here we see an example of a design
process that a project that was done in
the system exam icks used complex with
two towers and here you can see early
stages of the design process quick
sketches
and then designer took one of the two
towers and took it developed it further
again now sketching into opacity and
adding more detail again this is just a
bunch of strokes in space
so so far what I've shown is sketching
pretty much devoid of any sort of
context and of course architecture is
all about design in spatial context so
one of the things that we've been
exploring recently is how can we provide
some context for sketching that is
lightweight and amenable to the kind of
sketching that mental canvas affords so
there are a variety of different kinds
of representations available one is
panoramas which are very helpful in
giving a broad view of a context but
they're not so useful at a certain point
because they only have a single
viewpoint and they don't offer any sort
of occlusions and that's very important
in a variety of different kinds of
spatial context at the other end of the
spectrum we could look at full 3d models
they're way too detailed and often
extremely difficult to acquire so often
also not particularly suitable for
providing context for sketching so in
very recent work we've been looking at
how we can represent designs in context
and this example of Frank Lloyd Wright's
Coffman house is a kind of example
that's very very challenging because
here of course you have both the belt
structure and the landscape are embedded
so recently we've been trying to look at
ways that we might provide a kind of
lightweight context so here's an example
of real video taken of a rural site and
the question we're interesting is how
can we represent a complex setting like
this in a form that's amenable to
conceptual design we've been working
recently on something called inside to
which is a kind of extension of mental
canvas
which is intended to provide such a
lightweight representation for sketching
so inside to leverages the availability
of data about sites from things like
google maps and bing maps as well as
elevation and aerial photos and simple
site measurements and photographs so the
idea is that we can take these
photographs taken with a digital camera
variety of site data that are that's
available and some basic site plan
measurements and combine that to into a
kind of backdrop that can be used for
sketching here's an overview of how of
all pieces here go together we take
these input various types of search
their site surveys photos and so on
import them into our system and first we
create a kind of aerial from the aerial
map in elevation data we create a kind
of a height field or a canvas that has
height that represents terrain this can
be combined with aerial photographs on
the left here you can see a one of these
height field meshes and then the terrain
with the aerial photo applied and one of
the things that if you go out and take a
lot of pictures of a site what's
important for being able to use such a
representation for sketching is that you
need to know where you are so we use a
simple set of measurements something
like eight stakes in a complicated site
to provide a kind of scaffold to hang
pictures and we also make use of basic
GPS measurements and from that we can
figure out where we are on the site and
hang photos if you will and and
structure the site so that it can be
used for sketching this just shows the
ability to take a few measurements
combine them together and figure out
where cameras are and eventually we can
create some kind of two and a half D
representations that we can use
underneath are sketching system so one
of the things we do is we import bundles
of photographs so you could take
hundreds of images of a site and then
have them all kind of registered if you
will within the context that you're
creating and also organize them in a way
that it becomes simple to navigate we
also have some interactive tools so that
you can create linked pop-ups so you
could start out with a photograph like
this we can automatically with minor
sort of modest user intervention
estimate where the camera was that took
the photograph we can go in and block
out some part of it as a pop-up and then
generate a canvas in space where the
pop-up should be located and this is an
example of this is a site that we're
working with a sculptor on who she's
designing a large sculpture for on the
new section of the High Line so this is
how the lightweight context comes
together so here's the imported
elevation data again this is available
for just about any site and then we
apply the aerial map
and then this is importing point cloud
so if you've taken a whole bunch of
photographs of the site these are now
localized and then you can go in and
create pop-ups and this is an
interactive process because with any
site a designer often has particular
features he or she finds important and
so we have the ability to go in and and
pull those out so this is a we start out
with a real site now we've this is the
virtual site and I should say that this
can be represented with either
photographs or with strokes or any some
sort of representation in between that
might be more painterly for example and
then the interesting part begins here
you can actually sketch within this
lightweight representation so we've sped
this up again just for illustrative
purposes so designer is sketching a
house in the woods and note that again
the basic representations just strokes
so we're creating a canvas but you can
also manipulate the backdrop here and I
show this to show you that this
representation is actually in these
sketches are positioned in the site so
up along the top here you're seeing a
series of bookmark views and then all
the drawings that you make are
registered if you will with the rest of
the site and on the lower right here you
can see a bunch of different kind of
camera angles and this shows that what I
mentioned earlier about with a panorama
you don't have occlusions and so this
shows you can see here you can bring in
trees and other features on the site and
sketch around them or behind and so on
and this is another example this is also
a house design and this is without the
popups this is just using strokes and I
show this just to give you an idea of
what it's like this is just a series of
sketches against put together so we can
move around and look at particular views
but note that this is actually
incomplete if as we move around to see
that this house is in pieces it's just
it's not yet fully formed
our current interface is a cintiq tablet
display system which is a lot like your
iPhone or iPad so we're moving toward
making something that's really compact
and portable so that you can use it like
a sketch pad and have digital camera
basic GPS and all that all in one single
device against many ways the system that
I've presented today is like a sketch in
that it's a work in progress and it's in
that sense it suggests i think as many
new directions as problems we've solved
to date so many things that we're
looking at right now one is different
kinds of rendering styles lighting
effects atmospheric effects and shading
and we're also working on incorporating
a temporal dimension to the system and
the context that i showed you although
we're able to create this these pop-ups
that you can use to sketch we're also
interested in like as in the Coffman
house being able to actually edit that
context so be able to manipulate terrain
and vegetation to look at the interplay
of built form and landscape and another
interesting direction which we've not
explored yet but I think could be neat
is to create physical pop-ups out of the
system this could even be done just on a
laser printer and capability Brown often
presented his landscape designs as
pop-ups so in addition to I hope sort of
elevating sketching again perhaps our
work could also start to push more
toward elevating pop-ups as a way of
presenting and studying designs so I
just want to end by acknowledging some
of my collaborators and students in
particularly Patrick paszkowski who's
the lead developer on the system as a
PhD student
and also andreas faculty whose finishing
is m.ed thesis and you just learned how
to use the system in the past couple of
weeks and is made a number of the
examples that I show today and is
provide lots of insights thank you very
much second speaker is Andrew wit and
rowid is based in Los Angeles as
director of research at Gary
technologies he's also a member of the
architectural fact faculty at Harvard he
has degrees in both mathematics and
architecture is talk a reverse history
of mechanic mechanized drawing 2012 to
19
so first I of course would like to thank
Dean stern Victor and George for the
invitation present as well as the
inspiring an impressive presentations
that we've seen throughout the
conference so far I'd like to begin as a
point of departure with Antoine pecans
at observation yesterday the drawing
historically has played a spectrum of
roles within design of which the design
sketch for party is but one if the
discussion up to this point has to some
extent been dominated by the primacy of
the design sketch I'll take a somewhat
different section through the topic in
particular remarkable innovations are
occurring in our ability to make things
and the way designed ER and the way
designs are best represented in order to
be made the documents that describes
such processes could historically be
called measured drawings or construction
drawings indeed these drawings are the
currency of architecture quite literally
because they're how architects legally
monetize their labor and thus play a key
role in the professional self
understanding of the architect the
measured drawing has a history that's
somewhat distinct from the sketcher
party emerging as it does from the
legacy of engineered drawing in one
sense with this lecture I'll try to go
back to the future to suggest how the
influences that shaped the development
of engineered drawing mathematical
visualization mechanical experimentation
tacit ly continue to influence the
development of digitally enabled design
today in particular the sort of
parametric turn in another sense it
proposes a reconsideration of the
relationship between drawing and model
3d digital models are increasingly
replacing drawings as a key element of
project communication and construction
and that situation to some extent is a
return to an ancient state of affairs
after all during the construction of the
florence duomo it was the model that the
craftsmen swore allegiance to not a set
of drawings in a sense some years after
that moment the drawing might itself be
considered an upstart form of
representation a poor substitute for the
model lacking spatial clarity structural
analogy immersive quality
even material specificity design models
digital models we capture many of these
advantages and in a more versatile
within their physical counterparts yet
architects maintain an ambivalent if not
conflicted view of technology in general
in the computer in particular the heroic
view of architecture is an autonomous
and unmediated manifestation of the will
of the architect still holds public and
private fascination even technical
innovators may duly defer to this to the
self characterization of architecture
and often at pains to characterize their
work a design as opposed to engineering
which has become a pejorative term the
advent of a technology that's so
powerful fast automatic perhaps even
intelligent presents a subversive
confrontation to the architects
efficient and autonomous will or
knowledge the perceived association of
the computer with striking formalism and
tentative material resolution makes it
only more suspicious to the traditional
understanding of design so we'll try the
arrows here my interest in technical
drawing them mechanical instrumentation
that enables it was catalyzed by an
improbable find in one of the storage
cabinets at Gary technologies this
device the device pictured here is a
planned emitter used to calculate and
measure irregular irregular areas
normally on maps but also on irregular
shapes and design drawings it functions
by fixing a point tracing the other one
along the length of a closed curve back
to the original starting point in fact
it's a mechanical encapsulation of a
mathematical proposition called greens
theorem it's a physical way to calculate
integrals from the 19th century to mid
20th century they were used commonly in
engineering graphics but are almost
unknown today I'm finding one was a
little bit like finding somebody
wandering in the Sahara is very
surprising on many levels and it seems
to me a sort of clue of the unspoken
geometric and mechanical history of the
office a parallel history to
architecture itself of mechanized
drawing
so the digital revolution of the last 20
years in particular the latest
incarnation of parametric design and
deliberate intervention in CNC processes
has helped create a remarkable series of
innovative projects in short it's
enabled building that would have one
seemed unbuildable here's what one
example asymptotes Yas Island Hotel
which just which suspends above it a
constantly varying self-supporting grid
shell of custom fitted glass components
such examples of course could be
multiplied they've become so numerous
that we can easily forget how miraculous
they seemed only 15 years ago in
principle the design sketch for many of
these projects may have been done at any
time in the past but the capacity to
achieve them in built form lies uniquely
in the present new means of representing
design intent have also allowed the
synthetic integration and embedding of
design intelligence not only of the
architect but also of Engineers
consultants builders into a shared
adaptive database in short the drawing
has been transformed from projective
markings into a database of responsive
process intelligence and blurred the
boundaries of authorship inbuilt work
the sea reality of classical design
process gives way now to concurrency in
simultaneity the building in a way has
become a kind of wiki the radically it's
extended capacity of the model over the
drawing also facilitates the efficient
use of material processes which would
otherwise be impossible because of the
specificity of their design requirements
would forming glass molding parametric
metal stamping and of course now robotic
assembly required high fidelity and
machine readable representations of the
building in order to in order to
function this is only possible with a 3d
database which is inherently multi
representational the development of
multi representational and constraint
based models demonstrates that the
computer is not in fact a frictionless
and effortless medium far from it in
fact it facilitates an intentional
embedding of resistance through logical
rules and program responses in a way
that allows designers to
foreground design and still be confident
of constructability in such systems the
architect does not only design a project
but also a meta system in which the
project exists and is capable of being
realized in this sense architectural
authorship is rad actually radically
extended compared to this in a way the
paper drawing itself feels frictionless
and free of constraint new models embed
not only static material logic but
dynamic assembly descriptions as well
they are methodological armatures as
much as design tools frameworks for the
orchestration of labor and time many of
the contemporary projects share sort of
conceptual hallmarks that are
characteristic capacities of digital
design these capacities are not are not
at all new but in fact have deep
antecedents even perhaps precedents in
machine experimentalism in the culture
of engineering representation which
technical drawing in architecture with
which technical drawing and architecture
shares a lineage three particular formal
conceits are recurring threads
throughout this history first
combinatorial permutation of the
continuous evolutionary variation of
specific module elements differential
cartography or the mapping of subtle
quantitative facts or constraints across
a space or surface and swarm logic which
is actually the connection of
permutation and cartography that is the
use of informatik maps to drive the
different to drive differentiation
across an assembly contemporary process
is characterized by mass production of
customized details and it's through this
swarm logic that drawings become maps
and deformations of these details in
fact sophisticated 3d models have also
multiplied them the modes in which
drawings are used perhaps even extending
the spectrum of technical activities
connected with drawing facade maps model
generated fabrication drawings
representations of 3d survey data all
these actually extend the vocabulary of
what a drawing can and should do
in short the short disciplinary memory
of architecture with respect to
technical matters obscures the degree to
which the technical procedural
mathematical automatic generation of
representations indeed parametric
processes have informed the culture of
design and drawing for at least the last
two centuries in fact I would argue that
the professionalism or the society the
professionalization a design is deeply
connected with the emergence of
technical drawing as a discipline and in
turn with a mechanization of drawing the
current debates on the heritage of
drawing could be reframed by
demonstrating this long-standing
connection between measured drawing and
mechanization and trace the material
antecedents of our own visual and
methodological fascinations so why
machines in particular so ambitious for
making of the type that that I've sort
of described and shown requires a
virtuosity mastery of certain spatial
geometries it's a specific type of
design knowledge that's somewhat
specialized in and difficult to deploy
machines including computers actually
provide a way to encapsulate this
knowledge in a more usable and
repeatable way of course such machines
raise certain epistemic challenges they
abstract systems and detach detach them
from the attached the user from their
operative logic arguably requiring more
instrumental and less designed knowledge
from the user but they also offer the
capacity for enduring for an enduring
knowledge culture distinct from the
perpetual revolutions of ideology
stitching together the separate
epistemic archipelagos that litter the
history of calculated mechanical sorry
of calculated drawing can reveal a
consistency with which parametric themes
have emerged out of mechanical control
and indeed parametric practice carries
on a certain project of geometric
control through variation through and
its many guises has been apparent in
architecture almost continuously since
the early 19th century so beginning from
the recent past this presentation will
reconstruct a history or maybe maybe
more modestly a chronology of
procedural and electromechanical drawing
devices and build a narrative of the
recurring techniques in this machine
culture of design which is continuous
with our own preoccupations many of
these moments like digital practice
itself until recently fall at the
margins of architecture the various
moments in this reverse chronological
sequence design computation design
science mechanical combinatorics / just
projective and stereo Tomic geometry the
cartography of curvature proposed a
historical framework for the current
debate on the role and impact of
computational methods of representation
of course we'll begin with Bill Bell one
of the earliest progenitors of this of
this type and one of the first to employ
computer drawings to verify
constructability on a large scale
associated with the model is a series of
overlaid simultaneously simultaneous
analyses with specific and distinct
meaning these maps made the model
functionally polyvalent the Bilbao
process itself was a direct response to
the limitations of classical drawings
enough drawing methods which can only be
overcome through a digital multi
representational database here we see
one of the last one of the last projects
in the office to be done totally through
process of projective geometry the
catalyst for the digital methods wasn't
part the limitations of descriptive
geometry in the precise describing of
complex shapes the complete development
of such methods was taken to its limit
on this the wisent Museum where each
conical surface was developed in
painstaking detail the labor was
enormous and this gap in control created
the need for for digital methods
of course the cartography of complex
surface geometry had been a theme
occupying design for at least 20 years
prior and the use of projective geometry
and the measured development of
construction drawings itself as a
precedent in buckminster fuller's work
fuller in particular developed drawing
methods specifically for the mass
customization of his dome structures and
the construction drawings for the domes
themselves a test the variation required
in real terms to achieve a presumably
simple structure field like yet strongly
figural Fuller's mesh has become a
deductive and integrally unified
solution to a simple question of
enclosing space and the most efficient
means they create a compact and sewn up
world the geodesic method of disc ritas
ation was profoundly complex in practice
a cartographic operation in its own
right strangely fuller did not use
computers himself to calculate the
angular values and instead I use the
drawings as heuristic tools but Ron
Resch a contemporary a Fuller was one of
the first to use digital computers to my
knowledge in a generative way akin to
what we might call parametric today he
used them to calculate the
discretization drawings of space frames
supported by giada supporting geodesic
domes and engage problems of mapping
dynamic geometry in his 1973 paper the
top the topological design of sculptural
and architectural systems he details
what sounds suspiciously like a
manifesto for parametrically enabled
digital fabrication quote I will show
how the conception and fabrication of
designed objects have a topological and
geometric aspect currently these objects
may be characterized as emphasizing the
geometric aspect by limiting an entire
class of objects to be a unique one
finally I will show the introduction of
the computer into the design and
production process it makes possible the
topological aspect so that the
automation of custom-made objects might
replace a series of
identical readymades so that those in
1973 in fact in the 1970s Russia
undertook a series of
computer-controlled fabrication
experiments of tessellated domes through
to completion thereby becoming one of
the first examples of constraint based
automated design of fabrication Russia's
armature is the triangular mesh it's a
representation of a curved surface it
and plays a particular role in
architectures architectures recent
fascination with surface geometry this
fascination has made landscapes out of
spaces and spaces into landscapes the
articulated freeform surface of
contemporary projects have all the
complexity of geospatial terrain each
inflection in each fold must be planned
designed analyzed controlled these
surfaces accumulate whole sets of unique
cartography snaps of curvature material
stresses environmental performance such
surfaces compose increasingly field like
spaces deformation is a watchword but so
is control a precise and constant
interaction of design and engineering in
the service of determined effect so this
is this is Russia's film the content of
witches from around 1963 in the film we
see a series of physical models that
guided Russia's thinking all of the
physical all the paper physical models
are composed of one continuous sheet and
let's see and then finally we'll see a
his digital simulation so even hear this
there's actually a tactility to the
model as well in the process actually of
going through and creating these
prototypes I imagine there was some I
imagine there was a kinesthetic memory
being developed there as well so here we
see the process which he went through to
generate his simulations there was no
such thing as a screen so in fact
plotters were used to create keyframes
and then these simulations were
we're creating what's what's is doing an
interesting about these simulations is
the fact of course that they are
actually they're dynamic that they have
specific structural logic and kinetic
logic and so in a way he simulates the
material properties of folding in in the
computer within which for nineteen sixty
three and for all the labor involved in
all those plots I have to think is is
something respectable so here he even
dis aggregates the dome pulling the
pieces apart to reveal the unique maps
of the two the two layers so others took
geometry is central to the digital
process from the early 1960s the
laboratory for computer graphics and
spatial analysis at Harvard GSD held a
special position at this particular
intersection of geometry and design
funded in part by the Department of the
Navy which is kind of fascinating
because when you look at their document
they look like Declassified intelligence
reports or something funded in part by
the Department of Navy and known as the
birthplace of geographic information
systems the actual mission of the
40-person lab was much broader and
encompass what might be called
theoretical geography that is the
general study of the topological and
geometric properties of surfaces and
spaces the lab actually took on is a
project the abstract cartography of
surfaces studying topics ranging from
triangulated or irregular meshes to four
dimensional descriptive geometry they
engage problems of the topology of
connectivity and the implications of
form and space these experiments were
sort of visual manifestation of the
wider fashion fascination of control
theory and feedback processes during
this time the mid 50's it was only
slightly after the first patents had
been filed for computer controlled
machining equipment including the patent
drawings here for the first cnc routing
machines the engagement with material
form its resistance to the requirements
of fabrication was ground for fertile
research during this time in particular
the same devices that were used by rash
to draw and plot could be retrofitted to
carved material and and of course
artists took on
project artists began to appropriate
these machines to create design forms of
course the original form itself had to
be drawn mathematically but thereafter
the tool the tool itself would draw in
space or carve as we as we just heard
yesterday so Charles sure it was among
the pioneers of this new type of
sculpture so this is a sculpture of his
from I think it's also from 63
appropriating the machine to draw
material topographies and one of the
things that I find remarkable about this
is the sort of prescience of suri's
approach I think we're more familiar
with some of the some of the work of st.
Bernard cash on the on the left but Sri
is sort of right right in that idiom of
course architects were also fascinated
by computer-controlled machining and
indeed creative proposals for machines
to for material here we see a proposal
by renzo piano for a dynamic
electromechanical mould machine roughly
contemporary with series work so it's
kind of I don't know this is this is
kind of a fascinating discovery for me
to that piano actually would have made
these projections around machine
articulation of of fabrication so
Russia's work with digital computers
follow the cinematics experiences
experiments of others with analog
computers and a number of experiments
with Auto oscillating wave machines to
simulate certain deep spaces through
overlapping line work and periodic
lissajous curves one of these is of
these desmond paul henry and hydrate
hydras burger specific examples so World
War two oops okay World War two brought
a new generation of digital and analog
electronic calculating machines to the
four including ballistics computers used
for measuring the trajectories of
missiles so Desmond Paul Henry created
quasi-periodic curve drawings with an
army surplus bomb site computer so
essentially adapted this computer which
was intended to to work in real time
charting the courses of ballistics and
instead applied it to drawing
so he described these these sort of
results as densely packed he Lisi's
subject to various degrees of distortion
both intricate both intrinsically and
extrinsically extrapolation of the
spatial implications of mechanized
drawing extrapolating those implications
Henry linked his drawings to Darcy
Thompson's formal analysis of spicules
cells and cellular aggregations
intending his machines to simulate the
evolution of these types of biomorphic
and mathematical structures speculations
if you will in the evolutionary biology
of drawing and I wanted to point out
also that the left drawing has a ground
plan and so I maybe there's an
architectural intention i'm not quite
sure beginning in 1955 Heinrich hiders
Berger who is an architectural
photographer undertook the construction
simpler but more spatial devices which
traced the oscillation vibration of a
light beam on photographic plates hydras
burger created several distinct
iterations of the machine the most
sophisticated covering over 20 meters so
there's him kind of immersed in the
machine the product of this machine was
a series of rhythmic Rams luminous
images of permeated curvatures these
rhythm a gram had deliberately spatial
properties engaging a relativistic sense
of space and time capturing something of
the cinematic and combinatorial
possibilities of machine drawing it's
not incidental that these drawings
leverage what we would now call the
wireframe in the wireframe a
prototypical digital representation we
have a pure oscillation of inside and
out it was a key mode of spatial
experiment in the early 20th century
taken up for example by Albers in his
drawings of structural constellations
but it also claimed a scientific
connection to the early 20th century
emergence of new types of mathematics it
suggested a way not only to represent
four-dimensional space so on the lower
on the lower left hand corner you can
see a mathematicians drawing of the
four-dimensional hypercube and then
vendas Berg's own high per cubic house
which he
to represent that spatial where he hoped
to leverage that spatial complexity I
guess it's a it also suggested a way to
represent the wireframe also suggested a
way to represent deep experiential
perspectival three-dimensional space in
a single plane the question of
mathematical measurement in particular
and the distortions and inversions
possible in a mathematically measured
space had set the stage one of the most
ambitious of these machines was William
Riggs 1927 device for combinatorial
curve drawing through the permutation of
gears of various sizes periods and
configurations it could construct a
whole range of curves sike lloyds
harmonic curves rig spent over a decade
perfecting his machine and it had a
range of about 7 billion distinct curves
to be exact well sorry to be exact it's
seven billion 600,000 anyway it's a lot
ok but I admire that he calculated it to
a couple of decimal places so the
Machine does became an empirical means
of exploring an almost unlimited space
of parametric permutations in particular
in this particularly suggestive diagram
on the lower half published alongside
his other research he shows a matrix of
curve families and their continuous
parametric inter transformation that
emphasizes in fact the stereoscopic
effects of his machines this matrix
represents a combinatorial exploration
and the matrix is itself I think is
still a very very valid and compelling
way to represent sort of combinatorial
span as as evidenced by the by the
seminal work of Greg llins embryologic
house The Rose engine a parametric tool
for the cyclic cutting of wood is
another example popular in the late
nineteenth and early twentieth century
all all the vanish today and what was
fascinating about these types of devices
that they gender they engender their own
type of literature which was in fact a
literature documenting all of the
combinatorial range of of those of those
machines so here we have the numeric
representation of all the possible
states and this
the graphic the graphic representation
of those of those states and in fact
these are only one of the entire genus
of combinatorial machines each
generating curve many with specific
architectural implications so one of the
things that we find in the 19th century
is architects actually specifying the
types of machines that they need in
order to create specific types of
specific types of drawing a sort of
hardware prototypical hardware hacking
if you will in fact it was the syntactic
project in architecture that catalyzed
this machine invention the volute and
architectural compasses became the
mechanical embodiment of an intellectual
project for the rational unification of
the orders this mechanical unification
has it's more distant antecedents in the
former oh sorry in the formal
rationalization of Claude Perot the
fundamental transposition of the
rationalization of the orders from a
historical problem to an abstract formal
mathematical problem made possible the
connection of mathematics and mechanism
to the ideological and historical
problems of architecture in the meantime
the new geometric methods of projective
geometry created in created a more
urgent requirement for tools that could
encapsulate complex geometric operations
rapidly almost algorithmically and
assist designers in the generation of
projections than intersections the
construction of conic sections such as
ellipses parabolas hyperbolas was
particularly key because these were
frequently occurring sections in in
production projected construction some
of the most sophisticated instruments
addressed design problems from antiquity
so the precise proportions and curves
that describe the profile the classical
orders for example where matter of
rigorous and laborious calculation prior
to the advent of such machines and as I
mentioned projective methods as well
particularly calculation of vault
intersections benefited from a specific
machinery in fact such machines became
standard enough at the in some technical
treatises they began to be recommended
as a way to construct those
intersections
of course the Machine culture of design
included not only drawing machines but
modeling machines as well kinetic models
which were used to generate their
sophisticated intersections so in this
case along the top of this model there's
a rail which you can position the two
sort of floating floating circles and as
you reposition them the intersection in
between is sort of physically
recalculated and here we see an example
of the types of machines that were
developed during this period of time in
Europe so at the top is actually an
excerpt from from the trees by Gian
Battista Sawaari from the 18th century
for some reason the 18th century Italy
was a very fertile place for the
development of these types of drawing
machines so his prototypes became an
inspiration for many later ones the
lower left-hand corner was a was a model
actually designed by designed by an
architect for specific use in
architectural applications and then
there's a physical realization of
sororities prototypical model just as in
the 20th century numbers became a means
to calculate curves in the 19th century
the reverse was true that curves were
just used to calculate numbers the
porosity between drafting and scientific
instrumentation and their
interdependence in cycles of innovation
is exemplified by Joseph Clemence
well-known draftsman and one of the
foremost makers of precision instruments
in 19th century Britain Clement won
national recognition for the design of
architectural drawing instruments
particularly those for the construction
of ellipses and worked extensively in
the manufacturer of automatic machine
tools but his most remarkable
collaboration was in the construction of
Charles Babbage's Difference Engine the
first large-scale mechanical computation
device between about 18-24 and 1833 as
the principal engineer behind the
execution Clement draft and planned the
inter workings of hundreds of
interdependent gears Babbage's project
to create a machine for the automatic
mechanical calculation of mathematical
tables marks the most ambitious and
systematic attempt at automatic
computation up to that point and a pre
figures in many ways the digital
computers of today and it's remarkable
I think that they at the center of the
project with a draftsman who was
intimately was intimately involved in
the creation of drawing machines
specifically for complex architectural
work of course sophisticated geometric
calculations of exuberant form had made
such instruments necessary particularly
for fabrication here we see the complex
operations necessary simply to unroll
the stringers of a staircase in an
assembly so this is the sort of
developed developed edge of that
staircase on the right in fact there was
a substantial sub literature purely on
the drawings necessary for projective
development of topologically
sophisticated staircases which attests
the most to the almost parametric
control of variational geometry it was
necessary to achieve 19th century formal
ambitions so if projective geometry was
an intensive mode of measure drawing
meshwork triangulation became an
extensive mode mapping terrain for a
range of operational transactions so on
the left you can see a triangulation of
india around 1850 and on the right the
triangulation of Long Island which dates
from slightly later here this is this is
a triangulation of the Himalayas
undertaken as that as as that area was
surveyed actually with the expedition
that named not Everest and you can see
in the across the bottom the sort of
unrolled geometry actually of the
Himalayas it's about eighteen eighteen
fifty through these triangulations
surveyors and planners mapped the
complex surface of the earth itself in a
purely abstract network of mutually
coordinated perspective projections
locally relative and multifocal the
detailed resolution of this framework
was constrained only by quantitative
requirements these geodetic methods
expanded the already deep connection
between cartography and geometry and the
understanding of landscape became a
mathematical endeavor so finally we
arrived at the early nineteenth century
and the two essential systems of
technical drawing that formed a key part
of engineering career
in which most in which many architects
were trained on the one hand we have
descriptive geometry a framework of
local control of complex surface
geometry so on the here you can see the
this is an excerpt from Martha's
descriptive geometry which shows his
development of certain tangent surfaces
on the other hand we have performant
performative cartography which emerged
from military engineering more operative
and generative than surveying the design
of fortifications was dictated by
siegecraft stratagems and ballistics
calculations its geometry was not only
planimetric but sectional as well
drawing on the parabolic profiles of
ballistics in order to calculate the
proper elevation ramp elevation ramp
conditions for the fortifications by
translating the parameters of this
control angles of wall declination
trajectories of combat engagement and
radii of ballistic ranges into
mathematical into a mathematical system
the problem of state power was
radicalised into a geometric formula in
these two systems one for local
representation the other for global we
find something of an ancestry for the
contemporary project of cardio graphic
parametric design so the trajectory is
woven through this chronology and full
evidence in the work and debate of
digital practitioners today the
divergent and conflicting approaches of
these practitioners I think conceal a
common conviction however tacit that the
computer has radically expanded the
scope of the possible in architecture
yet this new possibility comes with this
new possibility becomes fundamental
questions about autonomy and authorship
autonomy implies a sort of Independence
of the syntactic and rational systems of
architecture from the extrinsic
technical from extrinsic technical or
ideological constraints also firms the
role of the architects will whose
syntactic choices in turn sustain the
autonomy project this truly autonomous
active will implies a sort of epistemic
self-sufficiency the designer has a
specific knowledge to create form and
instruments that could imply that the
designers knowledge or capacity is
incomplete call into doubt this heroic
view of architecture and authorship
thus the disciplinarian plication of the
computer hinge on questions of knowledge
does the computer as an intelligent tool
enhance or diminish the capacity of the
architect can the computer or software
encapsulate knowledge if yes can a user
be said to know can be easily said to
know a process that is abstracted
encapsulated and automated in a machine
do machines in and of themselves
represent a sort of latent knowledge
perhaps and hopefully these questions
will be best answered by the future
history of architectures new medium
thank you very much
thank you Andrew our next figure is
Patrick Schumacher who has a background
in philosophy and architecture studied
in Bonn London and Stuttgart started
working with zaha hadid in 1988 his talk
is titled medium and and form the
drawing within the autopoiesis of
architecture in relates to the title of
his recently published book the
autopoiesis of architecture volume 1 has
come out I think while you've to is
coming out in a spring yep
can bring that up okay good morning well
this was a very very fascinating talk
thanks a lot very insightful and for me
love new interesting aspects of the
history I'm kind of working within we
didn't know I was working with it my
talk today is delivering some series of
distinctions which cross the divide
between traditional drawing and
contemporary digital modeling and
parametric modeling and scripting under
the notion of architectures medium and
the design medium as universal
possibilities which I feel has massively
expanded obviously through the
incorporation of the new digital design
towards oh this wasn't fixed
I will not say much but these are the
kind of phrases or notions which came to
mind when i was listening to yesterday's
debates 3 on the side of relating to the
hand and the other three relating to the
computer to be clear my understanding is
the drawing is dead in the sense of
elaborated hand drawings on traditional
drawings but the free freehand sketching
is still continuing and but I think the
concept that or the category and
scheduling needs to be elaborated
there's many different types different
functions for instance there is a
distinction between the replete and the
attenuated it's quite a different matter
whether sketch is just indicating series
of travel external relations like an
organizational diagram but most of the
specific aspects characteristics and
formal aspects of the sketch irrelevant
and to be abstracted from versus a
sketch which is teasing out a formal
composition some formal characteristic
stylistic elements and aspects where
everywhere where every aspect and
feature the moment of the drawing is to
be paid attention to incur it force from
drawing to drawing into the final
project like for instance some of the
sketches which are deed has been doing
so there's a big kind of range depending
in what stage in the design process with
what functions with what aspect of final
architecture the sketch is contributing
to and I think there is different modes
of reference to be distinguished
denotation exemplified education and
expression which are operating in this
domain of sketch wise representation and
these two sets of distinction I'm taking
from Nelson Goodman's reflections on
notational systems and in his book the
languages of art
I just want to flick through some of the
work we've been able to create on the
back of the new digital design tools
which I'm promoting and which would not
have been possible as was pointed out
earlier with the traditional tool set so
they needs to be celebrated as a new
universe of possibilities of elaboration
of design and construction but it's also
already on the liberation of desires and
designs the build-up of much in turmoil
integral and rich complexity in the
design independent of the question of
constructability is already evident with
the new kind of sets of tools so I think
there is a thoroughly humanizing set of
tools rather than dehumanizing and I
think also if you look back I'm growing
up in a period where we had to spend
hours and hours trying to build up
drawings and waste our time and break
our backs that was in retrospect rather
dehumanizing and I exhilarated about the
new kind of freedom and light-footed
news and versatility of building up
designs the reflection of the design
medium is in fact come about I think
through the challenge of what having it
taken for granted standard sets of
drafting and designing that expansion
through the digital possibilities and
for the first time delivering choice of
medium and therefore posing the question
of the medium as something not to be
taken for granted I think that it has
burned a very interesting discourse on
the medium and in my writings I have in
each of the two volumes there is a major
part dedicated in part one to the medium
and part to the design process I mean
volume to the design process reflecting
that and I'm proposing for instance just
picking out one of the CSIs of volume
one architecture depends upon its medium
the drawing or digital model now in the
same way that the economy depends on man
and politics depends on power it
sustains a new plane of communication
that depends upon the credibility of the
medium and remains inherently vulnerable
to inflationary tendencies I will
elaborate on this in a bit first of all
in the most general terms the medium is
any reservoir of loosely coupled
elements that allows for the formation
of forms as strict couplings of elements
selected from within the medium for
instance the sentence sentence these are
forms or strict couplings of word from
to the medium of language understood as
a reservoir of loosely coupled words or
vocabulary and in the same way the drawn
or modeled architectural forms are
strict couplings from graphic geometric
elements of primitive selected from the
medium of the drawing a digital model
and now these mediums proliferate in the
question is what primitives and sets of
rules of creating Street couplings are
we actually engaging the world of design
so the limits of the chosen design
mediums representational capacity and I
will also say imaginable and
constructive capacity determine
deliberately the limits of possible
design speculation and thus the limits
of architectures purview scope and
domain of competency ultimately which
aspects are we can we draw in to the
kind of design universe design world
through which we operate think and
project forward so this inside obviously
parallels the linguistic turn and
philosophy where we realize we can only
think what we have the language for and
that is a given kind of medium inherit
and develop only very slowly and as I
said earlier that we are now in a
position for the first time to select a
medium actually also develop new media
and architects have been involved in
this over the other number of decades
and it has inspired architectural
thinking and reflection for instance
like in Mitchell t logic of architecture
which is the treatise of understanding
the Constitution of design through
design words and it has there been an
inspiration to the development of CAD
systems which architects
kind of interaction with and we've won
since I'm collaborating with Autodesk on
many levels so I'm just offering a
number of other distinctions which
important to reflect the question of the
design medium first of all in terms of
the medium there's a design medium which
is the facilitate creative
problem-solving by the sequential build
of complexity that actually working
medium perhaps most important and
primary for us but there's also the
medium is a what I call a specialized
success medium because it functions to
facilitate successful communication to
outside stakeholders and that is
extremely important because only if
there is that capacity to it to explain
and bring stay course on board I'll be
actually able and even there to
communicate beyond let's say what
conventional solutions so we need to
distinguish the medium and its various
functions in on one hand constructing
the architects project which for me is
that kind of design development medium
but there's also the clients project the
engineers project in the contractors
project to be to be looked at anything
these are quite different domains and of
operation of what we shouldn't lump
together simply the model or the set of
drawings traditionally and the
architects project itself is would argue
divided into an organizational project
which is Antoine mentioned earlier the
kind of the way operate on a very
abstract level with maybe a part of
non-human perspective kind of bird's eye
view or more abstract organizational
relations on the one hand on the other
hand it's we need to the same time
always reflect that space spaces and
architecture organize a social
communication for not only bodies spaced
out in physically in space through
distance
physical separation but is operating for
sentient socialists being a perception
we rely on perceiving and navigating and
reading this basis so we have the
project of articulation which is to do
with the experiential aspects of design
and trying to simulate though these
aspects and appearance and experiential
attract ability of of environments
through the design medium as well that's
a separate project to sort to large
extent one building upon the other and
makes different demands and called upon
different aspects of the over overall
pan apply of design media which by now
is to be argued in the plural sense so
and I'm just looking at these two
strands designing the organizational
project and the articulation project and
how each of them moves through a series
of stages and building up complexity and
determinate pneus through kind of
successive layers and stages which
sometimes take and often now take up to
a year or longer sometimes two years so
there's there's this kind of drawn out
cumulative process of drawing drawings
or drawings or elaborating multiple
models and two classes of models but
these are two parallel strands and in
the end somehow they they're both feed
into the comprehensive detailed 3d
parametric model which then spins on the
one hand photo realistic renderings with
all the lights materials reflections and
the phonology of space and on the other
hand the more detailed files which which
which which let allow us to control the
detailed organization and technicalities
and objective aspects of the build
environment so these are two strands
which are tied together and initially
run in parallel but we need to remember
that a drawing or particular model a
particular extract of a model because
we're no longer doing drawings we we're
drawing as a kind of viewport
two-dimensional plans and sections will
exist but only as view ports or
extractions from these integrated 3d
parametric models but each item and also
the model is often a kind of cluster of
models work on imperiled by different
designers but also accumulating and
moving through time so we have networks
of drawings and the meaning of each of
them is depending on its position within
that matrix which has two dimensions
either the coordination of many multiple
fragments if you like which together
build up the kind of system systematic
global representation of the project and
the kind of continuous succession how
this isn't kind of evolving process
which involves over a whole year or
longer with sometimes a very late large
groups of people over a hundred people
and so each of these drawings or models
is just the transitory fragment within
that cross-reference that set of
drawings process through time and that
we need to remember to avoid this kind
of fetishistic metaphysics of presence
which sometimes overcomes us when we
just stare at a particular fragment
transitive a fragment of these kind of
larger processes so we need to remember
that the force effect and there it does
turn also what you might call the
paradox of the hermeneutic psyche cycle
that the meaning of each drawing depends
on its position in the matrix of
drawings the progression the progressing
succession of sets of drawings or models
and again all what I'm saying is
relating as much to traditional design
media and process as it relates to
contemporary ones except that the
content in the contemporary world is
much more intensified these issues and
so I think that needs to be remembered
so that the oval succession is one that
accumulates information in this long run
that process of two an arrow that
moves through money folder turnah tips
which are somehow not which are dropping
away but but they are kind of the
decision making process at the scar did
all the alternative is is accruing or
evolving it's something which is so rich
and dense of information intelligence
through what it all has left behind and
we always have this kind of horizon of
possibility to reflect on which the
medium afford or the various media
fought on the other hand we need to see
how that whatever we present has carved
out from or filtered out from this kind
of continuous process of proliferating
options and selection and deciding and
moving on and opening up a new set of
selections on a new plane this kind of
process is like an evolutionary process
of mutation selection reproduction and
and I want to introduce another concern
and aspect and this kind of time
structure of the design process has two
aspects and distinguish spacious time a
kind of do way versus point like time
what I mean by this is the point item is
that measured with a clock time which
continuously and irreversibly time
becomes past where I am where where the
before and after is is is made distinct
by a decision by make by placing a surah
by moving on to the next step in the
sense consuming options and fixing a
point to then open up a new set of
options versus that spacious present so
the point light present is that moment
of making it says you are making a
decision and tick clocking on and taking
on in time building up complexity and
the spacious presence also very
important is that prolong continuance
and where this kind of zone of
reversibility where we are kind of
lingering negotiate and have keep
options in the mix and keep options
open and that is what what the medium
also a force in many ways and what I
would argue is that very introduction of
the design medium the drawing initially
as against a direct engagement of the
built environment through self building
through construction through building up
a construct without the advantage and
and and and plane of invention of the
prior drawing drawing drawing design
process compared to that we have when we
introduced one for the first time in
divination also we already have that
moment of combining design progress with
the preservation of reversibility so the
design progress prior to the drawing of
course the design progress as as
deconstruction process and ex
construction progress and now we can
separate out and isolate design progress
in advance of construction and that is
relative to compared to the direct
building up of construct in real space
as the final product we have that zone
of reversibility of that spacious time
and I think that every single advance in
the medium is always about at enhancing
that ability to combine design progress
with the privacy preservation of
reversibility so when we're moving from
construction to the domain of drawing we
have that when we're moving from drawing
on on paper with ink to a kind of
drawing which uses starting to use
tracing paper entrance transparent
layers we have that ability to kind of
work over with tracing sketches and keep
keep kind of shifting and moving and
lingering in the domain of options
before we finally make a decision to
inscribe
these kind of browsing explorations into
the paper and then move and open up a
next step we moved from there into the
computational world where we where the
the world of design speculation becomes
even less material than in the world of
paper more malleable opens up more
spaces of reversibility and finally in
the parametric model where we can where
you can really build up a lot of detail
and precision and and build progress
design process while maintaining large
x-large to large extent this kind of
reversibility in the mix this is where I
see it kind of want you kind of aspect
of progress in the development of the
media so I want to now set this kind of
discussion into the broader terms of my
theory of architecture is it is placed
places architecture in the societal
context so first of all for me the
phenomena of architecture can be most
adequately grassroots analyzed as
autocratic system that is a
self-referential II closed network of
communications that's the discourse need
this kind of specialized discourse of
architects and designers theorizing and
argue in discussing their work starting
in divination zones in fact where where
you have for the first time the drawing
as well as the three ties and
theoretical discussion published
together and circulating an open
discourse so the architecture as expert
communication process relying on the
specialized medium of the drawing and
later digital model as its key
precondition to allow this discourse to
set a server and second premise is that
society is the totality of all
communications and and that within that
we have various self-reference courses
subsystems of communication like
architecture but also like the political
system like the economy I like the legal
system that's my kind of understanding
society has a cool a series of court
valving discourses each one taking up
particular responsibility and the
responsibility of architectural design
discipline is the kind of innovative
structuration of the built environment
as one layer through which global
societal processes are all that so
architecture is one of the great
automatic functions two systems of
contemporary society in parallel to a
politics science the economy the legal
system etc and I'm coming to this point
that the special efficacy of each of
these function systems relies on a
specialized medium of communication and
these have been developed together with
and emerged together with these function
systems automata discourses like the
drawing emerges together with the
architect as figure together with a
reflective discourse and together with
understanding of architect as an agent
author who actively of course embedded
in the discourse now projects and
changes society in its kind of spatial
dimension and I just want to allow for
that comparison of the drawing and
modeling and architecture with for
instance the medium of money in the
economic system that's also one very
specialized system of communication
which was able to set up and make the
economy independent and becomes a kind
of autocratic self-referential II closed
specialized system of communication
which takes up a particular
responsibility within society but it is
also through that specialized medium
setting itself apart and develops its
own dynamic and also the medium of power
and the political system could be
compared or the medium of demonstration
and empirical demonstration the sign
these are parallel processes which set
out at the dawn of modernity and these
media integrally involved in setting up
these autocratic subsystems and this
brings me back to this distinction when
architecture first emerged as autocratic
system of society and me to distinguish
architecture as innovative design
architecture from mayor building which
is tradition bound building and we have
all prior Renaissance elaboration and
build a box of complexity in the built
environment is a kind of tradition-bound
semi unplanned unconscious largely
incremental evolution along the lines of
a mutation selection reproduction
building up a kind of edifice which it
proliferates and succeeds but then we
have what I call the big bang of
architecture for the first time where
where this kind of unconscious a
cumulative accretion evolutionary
process which took many thousands years
and to reach a certain point we have
that moment of separating out the
architect as with the tool of the
drawing to represent and move from the
direct engagement with the physical
world into that plane of representations
plane of paper and suddenly with this
kind of VLT materialized representation
realm can very rapidly manipulate
promote and and communicate and
experiment with new possibilities and at
that point of course the initial
drawings are just representation of what
has evolved in the medieval city becomes
the ideal city but then sets up that
kind of rapid accelerating trajectory of
innovation at the same time if you
innovate and you deviate from what has
been done previously you need to argue
for that you need to convince and to do
that you need theory at the same time
you have theoretical treatise coming up
a kind of consciousness of innovation
like a nobody but you also need a that
success medium you can only gather
support and credit build up credibility
for your unusual and innovative
proposals which concern larger larger
stakeholders if you have that medium of
representation which can make the not
yet the unseen the different
perceptually palpable and compelling
through representation and the invention
of perspective was was critical to that
respect as well even to know as a
designer yourself what are you proposing
what are you projecting what are you
trying to gather investors a whole
community for four years and decades to
commit to two such a project you need to
have a compelling medium to envisage and
project such projects that's the aspect
of the success medium you can only
communicate and will only communicate if
you have a chance to be successful so in
that projects back into the into the
reality very quickly and then expands
rapidly to transform in a few hundred
years the physiognomy of this planet
globally so the function of the
specialized success media in very
general terms that covers all of them
also covers money and politics etc is to
make otherwise highly improbable
communications or social interactions
probably indeed a daily occurrence that
can be expected so money makes the
improbable probable name that we are
able to be relaxed no no envious on
locust with respect to the consumption
and enjoyment of others without
demanding i will share whenever we see
others eat we can do this because we
have money the universal equivalent in
our pocket so money it is doing
something
and offering a totally new dynamic into
the social process in the same i think
is political power and mechanisms of
holding and and projecting power it
makes the improv power improbable
probable also for instance in corporate
structures and administrative structures
in bureaucracies name is that we
continuously follow both general
constraining rules as well as the
concrete instructions of our superiors
against our natural instinct desires and
immediate drive for organic comfort so
this kind of long chains of
constructions command the great
integration of many forces in the
division of labor needs needs them
specialized medium of power we need the
specialist media of money of integrating
that and having many money folds and
different and individualized these i
asked and fulfilled and exchange
wherever we like and I think the medium
of drawing is doing something similar is
also an a success medium medium it makes
the improbable probable name that we are
able to convince ourselves as well as
client stakeholders in the community at
large that they should invest resources
now entrust us with the creation of
complex novel unseen long-term built
environments that will not be available
for inspection before it has been
constructed a few lays down the law down
the line and that is kind of an
incredible suspension of disbelief which
we can only engage in on the back of
these powerful media of elaboration and
communication so and it in that respect
I think what was clear also in the
previous presentation that this capacity
on ever more complex and latched an
intricate scale with ever more demands
on to the build environment needs to be
demands that continuous upgrade of this
medium also for the purposes of
communicative success in the sense so
like money and power in their respective
domains economic exchange and political
decision-making administration the
medium of drawing modeling is
universally applicable in a specific
domain of operation so anything and
everything could be exchanged for money
anything and everything could be
instructed and and and and regulated
through through a political or military
of power and every and anything could be
drawn or design that that is the
universal you are you know it's allottee
of these media but I think it's also
important that that all of these media
need to continuously upgrade in this
kind of co-evolving ever more global and
complex and demanding societal life
processes so and I think this upgrading
concerns all these media so the new
forms of money and financial instruments
the kind of electronic money and and and
financial system based on computational
processes not only in terms of credit
money and and electronic money but also
in terms of calculating the
profitability and value of assets we
need computational processes the same as
the new mechanism of social control and
minister of power registrations and
statistics and all the tools and
instruments of of ordering society
through administrative process and
collectively binding decisions if you
like and the same applies of course for
the medium of architecture in terms of
the tying in and building on the
computational capacities and enriching
also the the models on the way was
discussed earlier with with engineering
constraints and intelligence and have an
ever more sophisticated and light-footed
and and penetrating and convincing and
compelling
set of speculations we engage in and
which we've left the what the kind of
hand elaborate drawing where you break
your back for for three weeks what you
achieve there is in is so far behind
what we actually required amount of us
today that's my point here so we're
doing timewise the overtime okay so
maybe I leave it here I mean